In my last video I discussed how adding a
single card to an EDH deck that simplifies
or circumvents a task that a player finds fun
can have a negative impact on how playing that
deck feels. That video generated a lot of
buzz and discussion, which was great to see,
and it also helped crystalize a handful of ideas
that have been sloshing around my brain for the
past several months. These ideas are complicated
and span a variety of subjects, but they can
be pretty straightforwardly introduced with a
simple thought experiment: let’s say you have
a tutor and there’s a bonkers card, something
very powerful in your deck. Do you tutor for
the bonkers card? Just so things are a bit more
tangible, let’s say you’re Enlightened-Tutoring
for a Skullclamp in a mid-power tokens deck.
A decently powerful tutor, and a draw engine
that is probably leaps and bounds better than the
next most powerful draw engine in the deck. So,
do you Enlightened Tutor for the Skullclamp?
I have devised four answers to this question
which segment four different perspectives
on EDH philosophy, and those go as follows:
Yes, I tutor for the Skullclamp
card because I like Skullclamp
and I want to draw a shitload of
cards, regardless of situation.
No, I might choose not to tutor for the Skullclamp
because the number of cards it draws
might not fit the vibe of this game.
No, and in fact I cut the Enlightened Tutor
because I don’t want the option
of tutoring for the Skullclamp.
No, and in fact I cut the
Skullclamp because the number
of cards it draws doesn’t fit the vibe of my deck.
It may be clear which of these quadrants that I
personally fall into most frequently—the fourth
one, I’ve found, no hate to Skullclamp in
particular—but I want to acknowledge that the
other three exist. I’ve gotten a lot of comments
from people who likely fall into one of the first
three quadrants, people saying something to the
effect of “but wait Alex, have you considered
this? I think you forgot to consider this.” So,
I now want to consider the other three of these
perspectives in depth and where they come from,
what core animating forces drive people to engage
with this format the way they do. I’ve split
this video up into two parts, because I found
that the first two perspectives here and the
last two perspectives here really demand two
different lenses of analysis. So, if you want to
hear me discuss the final two you can keep an eye
out for that video about a week from now, but
for now let’s get into the first two quadrants.
The first one is the person who does tutor
for the good card because they want to play
the good card. This is, on its face, entirely
understandable. Magic: the Gathering is a card
game where players try to win games, and winning
games is fun. More powerful cards win more games,
so they end up being seen as especially fun
in some sense. This may be directly related
to the fact that they win more games,
but in a format like EDH it could also
be a more indirect force—they feel good to
play, they generate reactions from others,
they have a mystique about them borne from
years of being heralded as powerful. There’s
a reason why vintage cube is one of the
most popular cube formats on MTGO—are these
powerful cards more inherently fun than any
others? No, but they’re famous and alluring,
and playing them pokes a little good card dopamine
button residing in the brains of a lot of players.
The EDH player who runs good cards and tutors to
find those good cards more often may be doing so
because they want to win more games, but they
also may just be looking to poke that button
more. And can you blame them? It’s fun to play a
Skullclamp and draw a ludicrous number of cards.
I think most players go through a stage of this at
some point in time—I certainly had the experience
of optimizing a mono black pile with Cabal
Coffers and Necropotence and such like ten or so
years ago, and I remember the excitement I felt.
For some players, that excitement does persist,
and I’m happy for those players—maybe they make
their way to cEDH, or maybe they just have a good
time playing sweaty high-power piles against other
sweaty high-power piles. However, for myself and
many other players, the excitement of playing
good cards for the sake of them being good does
start to fade with time. Trotting out the same old
powerful cards just might not remain as enjoyable,
and even if you do keep playing with them you
might need to change the way you play with
them to keep them fresh. One way this can be
done is changing the context in which you play
a powerful card. An Ancient Tomb that curves
into a Bolas’s Citadel is very different from
one that curves into a bunch of treefolk, and a
Necropotence that draws into an infinite combo
is very different from one that draws a bunch of
Clerics from the 2000s. Put another way, powerful
cards can go from a fun thing in their own right
to a way to enable some other fun things that are
a bit less powerful. This isn’t really a realm of
deckbuilding I tend to find myself in, but I can
absolutely see the appeal—you get the enjoyment
of playing powerful Magic cards and the enjoyment
of enabling offbeat archetypes that might not be
good enough with weaker support cards. And, going
back to the premise of this video, tutors can help
with this. If you want to guarantee having a piece
of powerful support to hold up your otherwise
questionable gameplan, tutors can be a good way to
do that, to have a consistent experience in your
janky deck. The game doesn’t have 10 Necropotences
you can slip into your deck, and even if it did
that might not even be desirable. Tutors are a
nice way to work around that fact. Okay, so that’s
one way powerful cards can stay fresh—playing them
in unusual contexts. The other way is getting
to the point where you don’t even feel the need
to play the good card every time it’s available,
and this brings me to the second group of players.
These are the players who have the tutor
and don’t tutor for the Skullclamp,
or at least they don’t always tutor for the best
possible option. I’ve found that these are players
who see tutors as a wonderful and freeing tool—you
can find whatever you want with them! You can find
a Skullclamp, you can find a land, you can find
a Leeching Licid—the world is your oyster. And,
there is a certain logic to this. Some games
you might want a power-card—maybe you’re behind,
or maybe you want a chance at catching up with
somebody running away with the game—but there
also might be other games when you’d prefer to
take it a little easier, play a bit lower caliber,
tutor for something a bit more mundane
if it better fits the vibe of the game
you’re playing. I believe this to be the least
popular of the four quadrants I laid out earlier,
but for the people who fall into it, I’m
genuinely happy for them. They are able
to have fun doing something that I struggle to
have fun doing—playing suboptimally on purpose.
See, I treat the format of EDH as a two-stage
game, as I discussed in more detail in a video
about combo decks last fall. During the
first stage, the deckbuilding stage,
I’m in creative mode, crafting an experience for
the future me to play with, thinking about the
sorts of decks I might be facing and trying to
fine-tune what I’m building to create the most
enjoyable games. During the second stage
though, when I’m actually playing a game,
my goals are somewhat different. I treat it as a
game where my objective is winning, and where I’m
pursuing that under a set of constraints. These
constraints consist of the tools given to me by my
deckbuilding self, as well as the limitations
of the type of table engagement I prefer,
which is generally very open and disclosing of
information I think my opponents should have. I’m
not doggedly pursuing victory at all costs, but I
also don’t like playing suboptimally once I’m in
a game—if I need to make a suboptimal choice or
hold back in some way, it pierces the immersion
of the game and kinda takes me out of it. I
still will do this under some circumstances,
but I don’t like doing it and I certainly wouldn’t
set up my deck in a way where I expect to need
to do it on a regular basis. I know I’m not
alone in this either—a lot of people dislike
playing suboptimally, and another segment of
players dislike playing against somebody they
know is playing suboptimally. It almost feels
like an insult—you could interpret somebody
choosing to play make worse choices than they
possibly could as them saying “oh no, I don’t
need to put full effort into this game, what
you’re doing there isn’t requiring that of me.”
Now realistically, the sort of player who is
okay with playing suboptimally probably isn’t
thinking this way, but for somebody who is in
a somewhat more competitive mindset it’s not
hard to take this interpretation. This type
of player may also seem very different from
most other ways of playing in the EDH format,
and indeed, it does take a different mindset,
a different perspective on the nature of
winning a game, maybe even different ideas
of what a game should look like. However,
going back to the two-phase idea of Magic:
the Gathering, this difference could be as simple
as reversing the ordering of optimization in
terms of deckbuilding vs playing. I play in a more
optimized style and deckbuild in a less optimized
style, but it’s easy to imagine a type of player
who puts more optimization effort into the
deckbuilding phase and is a bit more laid back and
casual when they’re actually playing. I might feel
a little weird about somebody else making choices
that notably worsen their chances of winning,
but I’ve also had people complain about me making
the same sorts of choices in the deckbuilding
stage of things. The most dominant feature of
casual EDH is some degree of suboptimality,
and I generally think of that as being
in the deckbuilding part of things,
but it seems reasonable enough that it
could exist in the playing stage instead.
As a final note, going back to the
comparison between these two player types,
a way these two players are a bit more similar
is in the character of their decks. They are
generally both happy to play tutors, and they
are both happy to play with powerful cards,
maybe even when those cards might feel
a bit overtuned compared to the rest of
the contents of a deck. Fundamentally, these
things are just gamepieces, and having them in
a deck isn’t an obstacle to the fun for these
people. What I’ll be talking about next week,
on the other hand, is the opposite—it’s players
who are much more critical of what they put in
their deck, in one way or another. And,
as you’ll see when that video comes out,
those particular perspectives have philosophical
roots about as deep as it’s possible to be.
With that said, thanks for watching! And thanks
to Archidekt for supporting the channel. I’ve been
doing a lot of brewing lately, and Archidekt makes
it easy to keep my thoughts organized with its
nice visual layout and helpful category system. A
link to my decks is in the description. I’d also
like to thank my Patrons, some of whom are on
screen now. I just started taking submissions
for this month’s deck review, so if you want
a chance at having your deck reviewed by me,
you can sign up to my Patreon at the link
in the description. You can also check out
the podcast I’m on if you want to experience
more words exiting my mouth without giving
me more money. A link to that is also
in the description. Alright, bye now.